[Music]
can I get you a drink Abby agent
Gladwell am I in trouble you and your
friends the looking at identity
fraud money
laundering and transportation of stolen
property but I'm here to offer you a
deal we need you to steal
[Music]
something okay guys listen up our next
score is going to be our biggest yet
nice
half a billion in gold is on his way to
a terrorist
cell and the gold needs to disappear
what's your
plan we got to steal it midf flight
40,000 ft in the year we are taking the
plane the whole plane it's kind of hard
to take half a plane let's and
roll it's
impossible it just hasn't been done
before if we don't do this we go to jail
plus it's about saving lives come on I
don't appreciate the emotional blackmail
this is not emotional blackmail it's
blackmail blackmail it's treated like
any other lift we need to blend in too
much are you going F Gand off the grave
final weakness
yes you think you can fly I guess we
find out tomorrow go no if it was in a
movie it would go like hey let's seal a
plane and then you put your hand in and
people would be like d oh my
God all right then let's show them what
true Artistry looks
like is everybody in position you're
good to go
show
Showtime come
on going to shoot us
down we got to get to the back back and
load it back back back and load it back
and load back back back and
[Music]
load what's m what's mine the world it's
mine